je vais je vais pas mettre un pavé dans
la mare mais je veux juste vous dire les
chiffres concernant l'île de france
c'est à dire à peu près 13 à 14 millions
d'habitants il ya eu exactement cent
onze passages aux urgences pour des
suspicions de kobe hier l'accord sands
d'accord c'est donc là ça calme déjà on
a fait exactement 130 transport sur
l'ensemble de l'ile-de-france par les
transports samu pour des patients
potentiellement graves donc on n'est pas
du tout dans le schéma des autres vagues
je comprends qu'on est un pays qui aime
avoir peur et qu'elle se faire peur mais
il faut quand même savoir raison gardée
du coup quand vous m'avez invité à
l'émission en disant il ya une
inquiétude sur noël et pas du tout et à
part d'inquiétude à avoir sur nos sur
noël vous pouvez déjà préparer la soupe
les repas il n'y a pas d'inquiétude à
avoir je présente cette somme à des pays
mais tu peux sortir la dame dont canon
et et nous sommes un des pays d pu
vacciner nous sommes un pays où quelque
part on respecte encore les gestes
barrière même si ça a encore
laissé ali ça c'est clair mais on est en
train de se re discipline et donc ya pas
y'a pas avoir peur il ya bien sûr un
variant qui arrivent d'afrique du sud
que je le rappelle la tribune sud est un
pays qui est quand même avec un système
de santé qui est pas très performant
lacina trick du sud à gueuler pour avoir
des vaccins on leur a pas donné
suffisamment de points pour qu'il ya des
populations qu'on pas été vaccinés donc
là bas le virus s'est développée nous
comme il se développe c'est l'écologie
du virus il ya des variants qui arrivent
là on a des inconnus on n'a aucune
certitude comment le vaccin va réagir
par rapport au micron ça on sait pas la
troisième dose qu'on est en train de
faire par un principe de précaution eh
ben on va voir ce que ça va donner mais
a priori déjà parce que je trouve très
rassurant c'est que je vous assure c'est
pour ça que je suis j'ai accepté votre
invitation ce soir tous les malades
graves que l'on prend en charge ne sont
pas vaccinés douce d'accord ce qu'on
prend en charge et qu'une apologie parce
que c'est vrai que le dax 1 5 c'est des
formes frustre c'est à dire des formes
bénignes donc c'est pour ça que j'aurais
insiste sur le fait il faut se vacciner
c'est vraiment très important et il ya
des populations qu'il faut
particulièrement à laquelle il faut
particulier en suggérait de ce fait avec
smith notamment les femmes enceintes
parce que avoir le pot vide parce
qu'elle est 35 être dramatiques voyez
donc ça c'est vraiment et le vaccin il
faut faire très attention
merci patrick 1 passe toujours un
bonheur donc c'est bon derrière il n'y a
pas de pour toi on n'y aura pas de
confinement ça s'est même pas c'est
exclu non non je ne crois pas je rappe à
dire il veut donc plus de ça je peux
vous parier qu'il y aura une nouvelle
vague au mois de mars parce qu'à mon
avis il ya une saisonnalité se dire sur
con qu'il va revenir aux menaces voilà
il va toucher va toucher à chaque fois
les gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés il va
y avoir des morts qui vont être
principalement chez les gens évidemment
qui n'ont pas lieu matinée et il ya des
1,7 mais ça va être l'évolution par 1-0
2-1 et voilà mais ça on suit le rythme
de cette évolution et qui techniquement
gamme et c'est vrai que c'est difficile
parce que comme elle est sous le le
prisme comme ça en permanence de
l'information continue c'est difficile
c'est fois de rassurer quand d'un coup
vous avez toutes les chaînes qui de mise
on c'est une catastrophe mais c'est sûr
que sur le terrain et j'ai travail j'ai
travaillé vendredi soir et lundi
on n'a pas cette vision là sur le
terrain notre saturation dans les
hôpitaux à l'heure actuelle et sur tous
les autres malades sur l'épidémie de
bronchiolite qui est en train de faire
des ravages cassard sur l'épidémie de
grippe qui va arriver et c'est ça notre
occupation c'est la grise de l'hôpital
et le grand renoncement des personnes